der stellvertretende polizeipräsident
thomas berger hat heute ganz klar gesagt
welche konsequenzen er ziehen wird das
ist auch eine botschaft an die
täterschaft sie können sich darauf
verlassen dass es auf gar keinen fall
bei den 24 bleiben wird wir haben sehr
gute ermittlungsansätze wir haben sehr
gute ermittler bei der kriminalpolizei
und wir werden unsere spezialisten
dransetzen auch was das thema von
wiedererkennen von personen aus
menschenmengen angeht
um diese täter habhaft zu werden und das
ist der botschaft an sie
sie können sich darauf verlassen dass
wir sie ermitteln und dass wir sie
einmal bestrafung über unsere justiz
zuführen
das ist ein verbrechenstatbestand der in
der regel mit einer haftstrafe nicht
unter einem jahr verurteilt wird ob es
dann so kommt das wird die justiz
entscheiden das ist nicht unsere aber
dass die justiz habe normal schon jetzt
in richtung landfriedensbruch ermittelt
zeigt schon einiges ich gehe davon aus
dass wir in den nächsten tagen und auch
vor allem in den nächsten wochen sehr
präsent sein müssen als sehr wachsam
sein müssen und eingedenk unsere linie
dass wir unsere liberalität auf der
einen seite bewahren wollen aber auf der
anderen seite auch konsequent gegen
gewalttäter vorgehen wollen in den
vordergrund setzen und deswegen hoffe
ich am ende des tages dass wir
mittelfristig innerhalb von ein paar
wochen die lage in stuttgart so wieder
zunahmen normalisierung gebracht haben
dass die menschen solche szenen in
unserer innenstadt nicht mehr sehen